the only way women get better with age
is if it is if it's an unnatural way
naturally you look best I really think
women look the best at like 19 18. so
you know actually I think women start to
gain weight in college so it's probably
even younger than that but but the only
way that women look better in their 30s
than they did in their 20s is a as if
they were fat in their 20s so they
destroyed their beauty in their 20s and
now they look better but it wasn't
because they were living in a natural
way it's unnatural to eat more calories
right so it's unnatural or they got a
bunch of work done in their 30s and now
they look better but naturally you are
not supposed to look better and so when
women get surgeries and stuff it's
really cheating